hey youtubers it's Charlie so they just
announced that Star Wars red cup just
started filming it's the Han Solo movie
so I'm gonna explain what's going on in
the secret meaning behind the red cup
title we got to talk about garish Shrike
woody harrelson stuff we got to talk
about how it's connected to the new
films but I'm gonna be doing a lot more
Star Wars videos Friday is now like my
permanent Star Wars day so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and leave
all your requests for Star Wars videos
in the comments really awesome stuff
first they announced they're filming han
Solo right now by holding up this
clapper board here now you'll notice the
title red cup is in a font like High
Noon or like a classic western so the
Star Wars films were influenced a lot by
westerns as well as samurai films so
when the way that the tone of all the
spin-off movies are just a little bit
different this will be a little bit
lighter a little more swashbuckling
little more classic western then say
rogue one
but just like rogue one did they'll do
this really fun thing where they sew up
some of the logic when Han Solo makes
casual anecdotes about the Millennium
Falcon in the classic trilogy you'll
probably see moments like that pop up in
this console I'm captain of the
Millennium Falcon Chewie here tells me
you're looking for passage to the
Alderaan system yes indeed if it's a
fast ship fast ship you've never heard
of the Millennium Falcon should I have
it's a ship that made the Kessel run in
less than 12 parsecs starships not the
local bulk cruisers mind you I'm talking
about the big Corellian ships now
she's fast enough for you love me woody
harrelson hinted that he's playing a
garish Shrike type character who's sort
of a mentor to Han Solo that was from
this book that was published back in 97
so they might take a few liberties with
that character but you just read the
synopsis of that book and says Han Solo
was a child without a past a Karelian
street urchin abandoned foraging for
scraps of food when a cruel garish
Shrike whisked him away to a nomadic
band of spacefaring criminals now years
later Han fights his way free his goal
to become an imperial Navy pilot but
first he needs hands-on experience
flying spacecraft and for that he takes
a job on the planet lesya a steaming
world of religious fanaticism illicit
drugs in an alluring sensuality where
dreams are destroyed an escape is
possible so here's the funny thing James
Gunn actually took a little bit of
inspiration from this type of Oliver
Twist story star-lord is taken in by the
Ravagers this band
yondu is a little bit like garish Shrike
someone who takes care of Han Solo but
also has a very big temper so the way
they used star-lord in the MCU was very
inspired by the Han Solo character but
that's no surprise Han Solo is one of
the most popular film characters in all
of sci-fi history there are so many Han
Solo ripoffs out there next big thing
the title red cup has a secret meaning
just like blue harvest was all about the
blue milk for Episode four the title for
Episode eight was space bear we probably
won't know what that means until we get
to Episode eight but there are actually
two big theories about red cub and I
think that it's the lego theory but the
other one is that it's the Red Solo cups
just because Han Solo Solo cups red cup
but the slightly more Easter Egg
interpretation is that it's part of a
red cup that was inside a Lego
Millennium Falcon set big surprised that
the people that are directing Han Solo
are the same people who did the lego
movie so there's this very meta Lego
joke that's going on with this the
reason it's such a wink is because this
Lego Millennium Falcon set which you can
still buy today it's
the smaller one it's not the mythical
giant Lego set that all the fans are
always looking for it's the one that you
can just find casually at any toy store
there's all these normal things you get
these figures with it but there's this
conspicuous red coffee cup that just is
mysteriously there like why is there a
coffee cup a single red coffee cup on
the Millennium Falcon because you have
Lego people directing the movie in this
really funny Easter egg from a Lego set
just this funny red copy cup so we might
actually see a red copy cup show up on
the Millennium Falcon in some way during
the movie which set to keep our eyes
peeled when they actually release it
next big thing this story the only thing
they've actually revealed about the
story is sort of the time period that it
takes place during he's about twenty
nine when Episode four picks up so late
20s he'll be early 20s in this movie so
it'll take place much closer to the
events of rogue one so you might
actually see characters like Cassie and
show up during that now it depends on
what part of the galaxy he's in but
people did ask Diego Luna are you going
to be in the Han Solo movie and he just
sort of winked and smiled and walked off
so don't be surprised if you see a
couple of rogue one things show up in
this and in the way that rogue one
winked at the fans with panda Baba and
dr. Cornelius they might also have some
sort of Boba Fett wink in this too or
the Hutts
because if Han Solo is going to be
working with garish Shrike in this band
of criminals they'll be running into a
lot of the galaxy's smugglers so that
gets into Kessel run dealing with the
Hutt's so I don't expect to see Jabba
the Hutt but he might show up in there
somewhere
or at least be mentioned they haven't
revealed who Emilia Clarke is playing
she'll be the female lead the love
interest that isn't Leia I'm not
expecting her to play a lei or anything
like that because of all the controversy
with CG Leia in the new films Lucasfilm
saying we're not going to do that you
guys can let me know if you think they
should include Leia in this film even
though she and Han didn't necessarily
run into each other till the original
trilogy but she was such an important
part of bridging rogue one to Episode
four they could find a way to wink at
her without having to deal with a CG
Leia on screen because that might just
upset people more I feel like people
would be okay with Jabba or Boba Fett
but I will totally
be okay if they just leave all the
Princess Leia stuff for episode 8
episode 9 Donald Glover playing Lando
Calrissian they might tell the story of
how he got the Millennium Falcon and
they'll at least have to address that so
I'm assuming when the film picks up
he won't already have it they also have
to tell the story of how he rescued
Chewbacca from Imperial captivity that
was the moment when imperial officer Han
Solo had his thin moment when Finn the
stormtrooper is jolted awakened at the
sight of the blood of his friend and
tries to leave the Empire so Han Solo
has this moment when he sees all these
Wookiees in captivity so he frees them
and leaves the Empire he and Chewbacca
begin their lifelong friendship and it's
the beginning of Chewbacca's life dead
cannot wait to see how Chewbacca deals
with this life-debt situation when he
gets his hands on kylo Ren again but
most of you are probably loosely aware
of Han Solo's history some of that is
canon now some of it's not canon anymore
I would recommend that you check out the
paradise snare book technically it
wouldn't be canon but I think that
they're borrowing some elements from
that so the story won't be exactly like
that and you can let me know which
characters from the classic trilogy you
want to see appearances from I'm not
expecting to see Luke Leia but maybe
some of the other characters that are
just specific to Han Solo like Jabba
Boba Fett the other characters of the
underbelly of the galaxy
next big thing what about connections to
the last Jedi in the new films even the
original trilogy that's really where you
get to chew bakas character because he's
like the common denominator with this
Han Solo movie and all the other films
he has all these memories of the time
that they've spent together Rey will
probably learn about that as they travel
together but what I'm hoping is is that
they actually just use a red cup or just
some object of Han Solo's the Millennium
Falcon itself is really just the big
identifier of Han Solo and sort of
passed that along to the other
characters
and that it has some special
significance to kylo Ren before the end
of the new trilogy so just remember that
the solo film is all about the solo
lineage and as much as kylo Ren is the
grandson of Darth Vader that's typically
what everybody thinks about when they
him because the way he dresses he's such
a Vader fanboy
he's also the son of Han Solo it's part
of the solo lineage so I did a video
about how Adam driver explained that
we're gonna see kylo ren's humanity
learn more about his character in his
motivation in Episode eight so I had a
link to that at the end of this but you
guys can let me know how do you want
them to weave Han Solo in the way they
weaved broke one in with the other films
like they sewed up Death Star logic
there aren't too many plot holes with
Han Solo there are a couple plot holes
during the original trilogy like them
waiting a year to go save him from Joppa
they could have also paid his bounty at
any time there's really not that many
big plot holes as there were with that
Death Star weakness but I think it's
gonna be a lot of fun Alden Ehrenreich
is actually a pretty great actor I think
he's perfect for Han Solo and if you
guys didn't know they actually
auditioned way more actors for young Han
Solo they looked at thousands and
thousands of actors way more than they
did when they were casting Anakin
Skywalker
during the prequels so I just think it's
funny that they're attaching that much
more importance to the Han Solo
character than they did to the classic
Anakin Skywalker character but you have
to imagine that this is a different time
people are placing a lot more importance
on the Star Wars movies so they just
want to make sure that they get it right
but as we learn more about the film I'll
do more Han Solo videos most of my Star
Wars videos now are about the last Jedi
I'll be doing another one this Friday
believe all your Star Wars video
requests in the comments below there's
gonna be a whole bunch of Star Wars
happening this year 2017 2018 are gonna
be huge for Star Wars where you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for my Snoke backstory video and you can
click here to learn all about what's
going on with the Aquaman movie thank
you so much for watching everybody in
Saipan I'll see you in the next video me
me me me
[Music]